so you talked about uh the combustion
chamber and how damn hot things get uh
high pressure
a lot of heat uh how do you keep the
thing cool you have a great video on
this how do you get it from uh from what
you call it metal Rich engine Rich
engine Rich from like the the metal from
melting well one of the ways is to let
it be engine Rich there's actually you
can use ablative cooling you can
literally let
um make the walls thicker than you
normally make it make it out of a
material that will ablate away that will
kind of chip away and take some of the
heat away with it it's very again
primitive and it's actually what SpaceX
first used on their first Merlin engines
they used ablative cooling
um so it's basically a carbon nozzle and
you just let it get the carbon the inner
layer of the of the engine was not of
his carbon and you just let it get
chewed away and eaten away and that's
just something you factor in uh it's not
a very elegant and it's definitely not
reusable in that sense so there's
probably really good models about like
how it melts away the rate at which
melts away to know what thickness yeah
but boy that's a dangerous right this is
part of the design it seems so silly so
obviously you probably you know it's
again it's not the most elegant and the
problem too your geometry physically is
changing too because as you're eroding
the walls now things like your expansion
ratio or the ratio between your throat
and the nozzle exit is changing yeah
because the thickness like the throats
diameters actually like everything is
changing so it's it's not great it might
might not be melting away uniformly
there could be some like weird pockets
for aerodynamics to have to it's just a
bunch of chaos just can which I can't
imagine having to like figure all that
stuff out honestly yeah
um so the uh the more elegant thing to
do there's there's a couple other things
you can do but the kind of the most
common one especially when we're dealing
with liquid field Rockets is something
called regeneratively Cooling and the
the idea is you basically just flow fuel
or fuel or oxidizer through the walls of
the of the nozzle in the chamber
um before they go through like into the
injector or into the actual combustion
chamber by doing that your your taking
heat out of the you know you're taking
heat out of the metal the walls and
you're putting it into the propellant so
you're typically heating the propellant
up which is remember when I said there's
a gas interaction versus a liquid like
liquid gas lots of times even if you
pump them both that you know as
um they you know both being pumped as
liquids by the time it goes through the
walls of the chamber lots of times one
of them is Phase changed into a gas so
now you do have that gas liquid
interaction that's because they're using
that the fuel or the oxidizer to to cool
the walls of the of the engine so when
you look at a rocket engine although it
looks like you know a nice beautifully
uniform cylinder you know smooth thing
um there's either there's sometimes like
uh the channels actually like milled
into the walls that they run fuel
through and even though they're tight
you know they can be like two three
millimeters thick they'll actually still
have a channel that goes down and
u-turns and comes around and comes back
all the way down to the tip of the
nozzle and everything so it's it's just
insane that you know that that's
pre-designed and that's that's like uh
so they design those Channel yeah
there's probably some optimization there
and like how the flow happens well
especially because you you're thinking
about a conical thing or like a some
iconical thing where the the area is
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
you're flowing the same amount of
propellant through it as you are down
you know what I mean like the propellant
has to so they have all these unique
things like you know sometimes uh
different manifolds where they'll inject
more or less fuel in certain areas and
there must be like propellant simulation
software because they can't surely can't
like
test this on actual physical
well back in the day they had to just
build it well you mean back back in the
day
walked up uphill in both ways it was
like I mean like any anything back in
the day before computers were you like
had like
he just had to do it and like your
simulation or modeling was like a sheet
of paper where you're like calculating
stuff well but you can heat flux you
know like you can literally see how much
energy and how much heat is inside the
combustion chamber how much you know and
that is a a measurable thing even
without a computer now I'm not near
smart enough to do any of this like I've
never tried measuring the heat flux of
anything I barely even know what that
means I'm just smart enough
but that is something that people would
calculate and they find out okay copper
you know does a better job of
transferring the heat between the walls
of it and into the propellant blah blah
blah compared to XYZ
um so yeah you know materials people I
like I've met just in all walks of life
especially just through MIT through
everywhere where there's some people
are just like a hundred X smarter than
anyone you've ever met at a particular
thing like you mentioned copper they'll
know the heat dissipation through
different materials they'll understand
that like more than it's like holy [__]
it's possible for human beings to deeply
understand a thing dude Aerospace is
full of that you'll have people that are
so niche in some thing that no one like
the average person has never even
remotely thought of yet this person has
done it 40 000 different ways in a you
know in a an environment being like well
we found out that if we turn it four
degrees that way and add four percent
niobium you know like just things you're
like
what is your life and how do you know
this and the funny thing about them they
usually don't think it's a big deal yeah
they're usually like they're they're so
nonchalant about it that if you don't
actually you have to know enough you
actually have to know quite a lot to
appreciate
how much more they know yeah because
otherwise you won't even notice it
because there are popular culture
doesn't celebrate the intricacies of uh
scientific or engineering Mastery which
is interesting there's all these people
that lurk in the shadows they're just
Geniuses yes like you see you'll have
like the LeBrons who are like good at
basketball so we understand that they're
good at basketball they do this thing
with the ball and the hoop and they do
like it really well better than a lot of
other people under pressure like we
celebrated big public spectacles yeah
look how great they are yeah but like
the people like yeah as at these
aerospace companies in NASA SpaceX
the kind of stuff they're doing just I
mean there's Geniuses there and it's
actually really inspiring I mean I've
um I've interacted with a lot of
brilliant people in the software world
and maybe because I don't deeply
understand a lot of Hardware stuff
materials engineering mechanical
engineering those people seem like so
much smarter I mean it's always like the
grass is green or whatever the
expression is but there's a depth of
understanding that Engineers have that
do like mechanical engineering that's
just awe-inspiring uh to me well not to
get too like uh X well I don't know what
the word would be introverted or
something or whatever but that's
actually kind of the whole point of
everyday astronaut like that's almost
the whole point of what I do each year
from the beginning I did a thing called
the Astro Awards trying to be like an
award show hoping to you know lift up
and celebrate and and China Spotlight on
the people that are actually doing the
hard work and try to treat them like the
the rock stars that they are that we
don't know about and I think that's one
of the things that for sure I think you
know I think Elon definitely helped make
space fight cool helped make that like a
celebration thing where people are
physically out cheering for rockets and
Science and Space exploration but I
think that's just the beginning you know
I think like this should be a thing
where the general public uh looks to
these people as as the coolest ones as
the the coolest places to work as the
most important things you know sports
are great and everything I'm a big
formula one fan and things like that but
you know at the same time like if we
should be celebrating the people doing
this crazy work you know clocking in
countless hours just trying to figure
out this one little thing that's going
to help us further our understanding I
mean what's cooler than a giant thing
with a really hot fire that goes boom
and goes up into the air I mean like
there's no it's it's like to me like
bridges are inspiring it's like uh
incredible architecture design and like
the humans are able to uh uh work
against nature build these gigantic
metal things but like rockets yeah with
like a tiny little humans on top of them
yeah flying out into space it's like
it's the coolest possible thing
everything comes together all the
different disciplines coming together
for the high stakes drama of
you know riding that super powerful
thing up away from the thing we call
home Earth it's like it's so amazing
exactly so freaking amazing well I think
that's kind of part of my like story arc
is I I just used to be a huge car and
motorcycle guy like I just loved you
know things that go fast and you know
are loud and go fast and make lots of
power and at the end of the day like at
some point you realize nothing goes
faster and it's louder and makes more
power or the rocket you know I think
that's I think that's kind of where
where I eventually just ended up you
know wound up there just because there
is nothing cooler than that yeah that's
the ultimate level it reaches the car
guy is to become a rock guy yeah 100 and
at some point some Car Guys literally
become rocket guys and strap Rockets to
cars and try and break land speed
records you know like it's yeah it's
it's the same universe here and yeah uh
so Elon with your conversation with him
on on the Raptor too was talking about
what you were talking about like there's
an excessive amount of cooling to be on
the safe side as you're developing the
engine uh what kind of cooling was that
so that would be film cooling so
remember how a little bit ago we were
talking about keeping the turbine from
melting you can just run it off of like
off nominal basically off you know
typically fuel rich just run more fuel
through that so it's cool enough you can
actually do that locally kind of in your
engine so you can keep it so you know
imagine a combustion chamber and the top
of it's just a flat like imagine a
shower head and then you have like you
know the combustion chamber attached to
it the Outer Perimeter there the the
part where the flame front would be
touching the walls you can actually have
just more fuel injectors so you're
injecting locally of more fuel Rich Zone
along the entire nozzle and that would
be called film cooling so it's less
efficient though again you're kind of
wasting fuel there's fuel that's running
you know and your your mixture ratio is
off but only for a little portion of
your the big picture you know so that's
one of those compromises like you can do
additional film cooling to make sure
you're not melting your engine uh you
know but at the cost of performance you
actually but you can also be smart and
use film cooling you know there's fun
little clever tricks for instance you'll
notice on the F1 engine that was on the
Saturn V you know the biggest uh rocket
that had been built to date prior now to
Starship
um the F1 has this huge huge huge
engines there's five of them on the
Saturn V and you'll notice that like the
gas generator has a pipe that comes down
and then it actually splits off in a
manifold and wraps around part of the
nozzle
and that manifold
takes the hot gas from the turbine which
which is actually I mean it's not hot
it's actually cold gas compared to the
combustion chamber but it's you know in
human terms it's still you wouldn't want
to put your hand in it you know not live
um and it actually pipes that gas into
the nozzle so that it creates a film
cooling a an actual boundary layer of
cooler gas against the hotter combustion
chamber gas so basically repurposing
that gas that was normally wasted and
they pump it back into the engine and
then into the nozzle like kind of
further down so the trick there is it
has to be
far enough down that the pressure at the
in the nozzle because remember as the
nozzle gets bigger and bigger and bigger
the pressure is getting lower and lower
and the temperature is getting lower and
lower so you have to find this trade-off
point where the pressure is is lower
than that gas from the turbine and then
you pump it in and it's cooler than the
then the gas still is in the nozzle and
it can help not melt your nozzle so
you'll notice that the F1 is actually a
good example of regen cooling so the
chamber walls you can physically see the
pipes actually
um on the F1 because it's so big and
they just literally used pipes and bent
them and you can see the the coolant
channels all the way up and down the
engine until you get to that manifold
then from there on it just has what's
called a nozzle extension and it keeps
going and going and going and that
section of nozzle is cooled by the film
cooling of the gas generator
I mean the aerodynamics of cooler gas
and the hot gas
uh because you have to have this kind of
layer right to protect a layer of cool
like understanding that obviously
probably has to do in modern times
there's probably really good simulation
of aerodynamics but and to do it in
terms of pressure too like um to make
sure it's in the right place yeah that
doesn't like go back up go backwards
exactly if they have that manifold even
six inches too high on that nozzle yeah
it's just going to go upwards you know
and pressure always wants to flow from
high to low the number of options you
have here that result in it going boom
is very large near Infinity yeah
especially because I mean you can't do
like a small model of it maybe you can
no you can't you can't really scale very
well you know you have to you have to do
the full testing and that's why you have
all the kind of that's
that's why you have a Starship all the
tests that you know you think why would
you need to do so many static fires and
so many tests and why is it failing so
many times can't you get it right but
like it's very tough to get it right
well and when you're pushing the
boundaries you want to know where and
how it's going to fail that's right so
you can engineer around them so that's
that's a luxury that SpaceX does have
with the scale of raptor you know
they're building Raptor cheaper than
probably almost any other engine you
know maybe beside some of their own at
least at that scale
um then before they're testing you know
I think since last March or last April
they've tested a thousand Raptor you
know a thousand engine fires I guess not
just Raptors but
um you know that's just an insane amount
of data and an insane amount of edge
cases to learn oh my God we found out
that we're actually slightly over
spinning our turbine into this degree
and this frequency is harmonic at this
blah blah blah and almost realize it's
rattling and you know it did this and
then you can engineer around that you
know it's like it I'll ultimately you
know I think Elon said something like
high production rate uh solves many ills
or something along those lines and it's
just true if you have an insane amount
of engines and an insane amount of data
an insane amount of failures to learn
from you just know your system inside
and out you know those margins you know
where the failure points are you know
how to engineer around them and that's
how I approach dating no I'm just
kidding